we have a ladies and gentlemen i would like to
welcome you to ludwig
wittgenstein he is the pioneer and
founder of the philosophy of language and
thus one of the most important
philosophers of the twentieth century
he ushered in an epoch-making change,
the so-called linguistic turn, the
turning away from classical philosophy
such as  we she so canon went to the
philosophy of language what is it that holds the
world together at its core it is so
wittgenstein solely
language
all philosophers since antiquity up to
wittgenstein have as wittenstein says
basically overlooked the crucial point
they were blind in both eyes
they  have designed all kinds of
thoughts and theories and
systems and tried to
grasp and describe the world, but they
have completely overlooked the fact that they
can only do all this with the help of a tool
, namely with language, they
always think within language
and that is up to them  completely
lost de  nn no matter what a
philosopher says, what the meaning or the
core of our world is, he can only
do it verbally with words and no
one says wittgenstein and no
philosopher and no one can do or think anything
beyond words and
sentences  he says the limits of my
language mean the limits of my world
you can also
check that right away for you now use to
think without words and thoughts
try to grasp
thoughts without evaluation it is difficult it can not
work that's why wittgenstein says
this running against  the walls of our
capix are completely and absolutely
hopeless
i can of course force something like that i'll
give you an example i'll force it
now and tell you something beyond
the language
but that's no use to him for nothing and
it wasn't even a thought you understand
it wasn't a thought soon  I'm
trying to grasp an
idea I have no other choice because I'm sofo  rt
in there somewhere kabul I'm in the
syntax I'm in the grammar I
'm in the whole language game
German yes we can't get out of that
and
that's why he says there's
nothing at all beyond the language beyond the
language is nothing
if I'm in the  language think so
I don't have meanings in mind in addition to the
linguistic expression
, but the language itself is the
vehicle of thinking that is already a
very central quote from wittgenstein
the language itself is the vehicle of
thinking willi colum latin the
vehicle so the language is our
vehicle  of thinking we have to depict everything that goes on in
our head
in words and sentences
we learn the language in our
earliest childhood and since that
point in time when we can babble
we understand our whole world only
within this language structure then
no other possibility and that is why
wittgenstein says it is the  the very first and
primary task of philosophy
now  to look at what i can and cannot understand about the world with the
help of language with my words and my sentences
that is
actually the central task of
philosophy and therefore he can say
quote all philosophy is criticism of language
or he also says most of the questions and puts
the  philosophers are based on the fact
that we don't understand the logic of our language
the philosophers have always
said a lot of primitive things
i know i didn't
understand language logic correctly and didn't
use the terms that's why there are so
many contradictory theses in
philosophy
but now it's about that  that we have to
say what can we actually
say with language and what not and
wittgenstein undertakes this approach in his
famous book the tractatus logic
philosophie kuss this book has
just 80 pages and made
him famous during his lifetime
it is for a philosophical book
unusual yes for a book of
world literature that is so
brief but you know he asked this question
what we can and cannot say in
exactly seven theses razor-sharp like a
surgeon yes with a dissecting knife clearly
presented after it still numbered
like the bible for so the whole thing has what
apodictic it may be  it's great i can
recommend it yes and the interesting thing is
that he shows it in its
simplicity i'll try to
start now the first sentence from the
tractatus thesis number one is the
world is everything that's the case it
's actually quite clear who wants it
contradict it is the case that the
earth and is it is the case that is ne
gravity exists there is the case
that is an atmosphere is worth
everything is not the case we would
fly away or could not breathe so
the world is first of all what the case
it's the case that we're
all sitting here now and we're going to deal with going away,
so you can't
really criticize anything  tizing now
it goes further already in the next
sentence there is a very exciting turning point because
he now says the world is the
totality of facts not of things
so not everything is the case what we see in things like that
yes you could
say the  case is let's say
that i go out and then i see a
traffic light so traffic lights are the case then
i see cars traffic
i see streets i very fluid you
tricky traffic situation the case
maybe guardian angel i had my
guardian angel the case are oceans mountains
seas mermaids etc  then he says
no, not everything, not all of them are
more likely to fall, but only the facts
now the question arises what is
a fact, yes, how do we get to the
facts and then said we make
pictures of the facts, so our way to
the facts with them  we can then
distinguish what is really
the case and what i imagined is
going on in this way we get
pictures of the facts  hen biographers say
that he personally has this thesis, perhaps
also from an experience in the
courtroom, the young wittgenstein sat down in such
a hearing where the
two parties to the dispute actually claimed diametrically
opposite what
happened in the accident and the
judge with small automobiles
models and with brains and criticism on
the wall the streets are drawn in
exactly and let everyone
show how they see it and
through this picture of reality
tried to find out what is actually going on
yes that's why wittgenstein can
also say the picture is a model of the
reality and now comes after
wittgenstein it's not just the judge that does it
but all of you here in the room
i also constantly take pictures
of reality when i say the
publisher green at the traffic light i got the idea
that the
traffic light is red at the same time as the others  shows
and you have to wait for this model
d  I already have the reality in my head
when I walk over to the green and in
my whole everyday life I constantly have
such pictures of reality
but say it's not done
yet now he says wittgenstein the picture
corresponds to reality or
not it's right or  incorrect true
or false there is no such thing as an a priori true picture
i can be
wrong too one is wrong sometimes
one gets an idea and thinks like
this it has to work and then one sees
my goodness
it really wasn’t like that yes now  again
the question what is a fact and what
so what is a correct picture and what is
not when is a picture a fact
and when not and then says a very
central sentence in order to recognize whether the
picture is true or false we have to
deal with reality  compare this
banal sentence is the basis of
all modern natural science to
this day every natural scientist who
sets up a hypothesis, no matter how trivial it
can be  l be if he says at so
many degrees the water evaporates the water
boils the water becomes gaseous then it
must be repeatable in
reality the sentence must in
reality not be correct can then
some types i have to
be able to heat the water and always because the
temperature has to be up to  come to the boil
and evaporate only if it
is true in reality the sentence applies
so we have to check every sentence against
reality and he
would say, for example
, we cannot find guardian angels in reality
we cannot
repeat this experimentally
and unfortunately we do find mermaids
probably not either
and now he says it's basically exactly the
same making pictures of
reality is always the same in science
and in everyday life with us normal
people we make these pictures
in
order to understand the essence of the sentence
we think of  the uac ran writing which depicts
the facts it describes
t the writing and our language
that we use so naturally
is nothing more than a
series of small pictures of
reality that’s why he says here monument
to the hieroglyphs writing world
the hieroglyphs they simply made
pictures of battles with his bow
this is the end  lined up
they were just little pictures and yet it was
the first writing and the first language
and then finally in the
chinese and japanese languages
there are still a few
individual characters that are also direct
pictures the most well-known thing that is often
quoted is when  you make the sign
for a woman and there is a roof over it
so they don't
read like that, they read a novel if we make this
sign then it means peace and if you make
three women without this roof then
it means a fight so you still see them very
pictures today  linguistic
images are used directly for us it is
now only important that we know  that
ultimately words are pictures of reality even if they are
more abstract
yes
well the sentence is a picture of
reality as we think it
when i say a sentence it is a
picture of reality as i
think it when i say green  I go
the others have to wait then he
says his statement as I
think of reality yes and now
something comes second so that it is also absolutely
consistent we have to
be able to compare ourselves with reality whether it is
in reality like that and secondly
now  comes a second major demand
from wittgenstein the sentences about
facts must make sense sentences
about facts must make sense that also
demanded what does now he
does that really crazy thing in his
treatise
he examines all 16 so-called
'truth operations' you know you
can even to my knowledge  actually
in almost all languages ​​of the world
16 truth operations no
longer use no we  niger yes those are and
put those are not put those are
when then put they are either or
put both as attachments and so on
and so on yes and there you come to
16 pieces it's possible here in the room you
only have the chance 16 different
possibilities  to perceive sentences to
say interestingly the is
examined we all save the stone now
and come to the conclusion that there are three
different statements from three
different sentences about reality
namely meaningful sentences are loosely set
and nonsensical laws meaningful sentences
that is clearly a meaningful sentence  is a
sentence that describes a fact well
, for example the earth is
round would be a sensible sentence yes and then he
would say you can say straight
this sentence represents such and such a
situation because the earth is our
planet and that’s where the situation of
roundness is presented  but now there are
unfortunately also senseless sets that are often
used, these are on the one hand  the
theological sat and the
adversarial nld auto logical of
greek theaters logos logos the
logic and autos the same that the
logic of the same freely translates the
repetition of said pathological
sentence would be the mold is white or when the
road is wet the road is wet
theological sentences or yes  and
contradictory sentences is also clear
contradiction latin contradictory
contradictory sentences that carry a contradiction in themselves so the
teacher draws a triangular square on
the blackboard doesn't work yes or the
olympic champion came second
the little one and wittgenstein himself
gives the example i see a red
dot  the green one is
and then he says the statement that a point in the visual field has two different
fans at the same
time is a
contradiction and the problem is both
the theological sentences they are
correct they are always correct yes
so by  n  asser lane stv was at night
but they don't bring us anything because the
same thing is repeated again they did
n't add any new meaning and the
contradictory ones are
always wrong in principle but
neither of the two sentence constructions so
neither of the two can therefore
somehow determine reality well
now he has but not only
technologically contradictory are
loose sentences and meaningful sentences but
interestingly there is a third
group
and that is the group of
nonsensical sentences around which the theologians
and philosophers do according to wittgenstein yes and they
are the sentences
where,
so to speak, the object is
given meaning again  but this
meaning that we give the object
is initially abstract and no longer always
comprehensible in the world, so he says here, for
example,
if the sentence if that makes no
sense, it can only be
because we
have not given any meaning to some of its components
would be nonsensical  to Beis  game insert
the cause of all life in the world
is god he would say we have given no real meaning to
life in the world and the cause of
this life
because god is so abstract that
is not an inner world
assign the meaning that is not a
fact because we god  cannot
formulate it in a logically meaningful way and we
also cannot test god experimentally
several times is not possible and
that is why this sentence would be nonsensical, for example,
but also the use of hegel who
says that history is driven
by the world spirit parts of it hahaha so
we also made a nonsensical sentence and
then said  I'm already coming
to the conclusion that there are still so many plans in the last seven theses from the tractatus with which he concludes,
after we now know how we
will philosophize in the future and
proceed logically, we know everything must be
verifiable, everything must be
formulated in a logically meaningful way and everything
other what happens to another
and there  comes his seventh thesis, the
most important and much-cited and the
blasphemers, uncommented, at the very end of
the tractatus as the last sentence,
which one cannot speak about
, one has to be silent about it
and the sentence was so provocative
because it basically only left the entire knowledge
creation to the
natural sciences  thought about it and
actually says wittgenstein also the
correct method of philosophy would
actually be to say nothing but what
i want to say so
natural science set something
that has nothing to do with
philosophy yes and for
centuries philosophy has often made the mistake of
inventing its own words
just think of heidecker inventing abstract
words and
filling them with meanings
that cannot be checked at all
and that is why he says most of the sentences
and questions that have
been written about philosophical things are not
wrong but nonsensical and
nonsensical according to wittgenstein too and
now it's
getting heavier ethical sets ethical sets he says e.g. plato when plato says we have to open our souls to learn to see the good with the inner eye and focus on the good then he says the sentence would only be logically correct
and meaningful if  the good
would be defined yes but since blatter never says what the
good is he says at most it has to do
with the idea of ​​the beautiful and being
together
but ultimately the good is the
divine and because but doesn't say what
the good is and that isn't
defined  the sentence also nonsensical for
wittgenstein and science must be able
to give things concrete meanings that's
why in ethics one always tries
to say something that doesn't relate to the essence of
the thing and can never
relate it is a priori certain
whatever one thinks for
there may be a definition of what is good, it is always just a
misunderstanding when you read the sentences
in ethics that are also aimed at the
future  nft if you say you should father
and mother yours it's also about the
future yes or you shouldn't
commit murder and that can't
be determined empirically yes so that's why
ethics are nonsensical he can also
say that's why there can't be any
giving ethics can't
express anything higher it's clear
that ethics can't be expressed and he
goes even further he also says things
like the immortality of the soul
the plate and then yes also describes
there he says the immortality
of the human soul  that means their
eternal life even after death is
in no way hidden and he goes
even further is very exciting he says
even if you leave the sentence
unscientific and
assume it would be like that it would
n't help the logician because he says  the
big question we are asking ourselves here
is a completely different one
he says, for example, the question is he
isn't this eternal life then  ht is
just as puzzling as the current one
because the actual question that is puzzling for
us
is yes why does everything exist here
why is there something here at all and not
nothing yes why are we here why
does it work so why was there the big bang
why is there a universe and such  further and
me that's the question and he
said it doesn't help us that the
e-series is immortal the logician if he goes
to heaven he would have forever
to ask himself why
is there something here and why yes because
so to speak  the question is not
answered if i live forever on the
contrary it torments me that even my
whole life yes because
that would be the answer maybe
maybe god created because he was
too lonely yes because he was
n't enough for himself or he has himself
enough and it happened to him so
in indian religion it is so that
by accident god the world
slipped out and but whatever
wittenstein says  we can only
answer as the perspective of god
and we cannot take it because god
does not reveal himself in the world yes we
cannot make any statement about god
that we firstly can make logically meaningful
and secondly that we can verify
experimentally through repetition then
with a comparison  in reality
and that's why he even says quite
apodictically i think it's very
important that you put an end to all the chatter about
ethics whether there are values ​​or whether the good
can be defined and
at the end of the tractatus
just repeated that
philosophy often  only arises through
linguistic misunderstandings
and it would be avoidable
if everyone read his tractatus and
stick to the theses systems and
then he writes confidently at
least 30 years mine is also enormous
to write something like this at 30 which then goes halfway around the
world and then has  he written,
on the other hand, seems to me to be the truth of
the ged  anken untouchable
and definitely good but
it was very interesting
first of all good he was young yes you
will see in a moment yes it has
grown far beyond that later but first of all
he had this attitude and was
also very strict towards
himself and
how much  he was convinced that his
things were inviolable you can also see
in a nice episode when karl
popper came to visit wittgenstein has
at some point he was austrian then
accepted english
citizenship and was then also a professor
in england in cambridge and karl popper
was another philosopher  just
arrived from new zealand at the invitation of
cambridge university let it
work
community and was
supposed to give a lecture there and kept the
contract about the topic there are
so many problems again and it was such a
fireplace room all the philosophical
celebrities there were also some supporters  von
wittgenstein had it in small
clear to s  i went with the man
students who were enthusiastic about their
radical thinkers and wittgenstein poked around
with a poker in the forum yes in
the chimney before because for him there were
no philosophical problems and then
the britpopper jumped up and said
that was just a  mathematical problem
that wouldn't be a problem that we
formulated the problem logically incorrectly and
poppe was of course also annoyed
and papa then
interrupted wittgenstein again and
wittgenstein underlined his theses with the for has a bit
like the conductor's baton
and pop did  then
said literally i don't want to be a
philosopher anymore if there are no
really genuine philosophical problems
, for example no one
can seriously say
that moral propositions are not subject to a
discursive critical assessment we
may we must as philosophers when
a law is made or a rule
or a  someone says that and  that
is immoral critically
we question it with justification whether it can be justified
and whether there isn't another moral
rule that is better
we must be allowed to do that as philosophers then
that was far too much of course
for really a wittgenstein jumps
up with the poker for a while  pump and
and says
give me an example of a
moral rule because for
wittgenstein there were no valid
moral rules because we can't
justify them logically yes we
can't justify moral ethics we can't
really
justify them scientifically
and the interesting thing is now  that
dad then said completely calm when
he tried to stay calm had told him
yes he did play it and that
man shouldn’t guest lecturers with the
poker means
then
wittgenstein peppered the poker in so in the
in the chimney is out and has  the door
slammed
on this little episode i gave
you  n not now
told again for amusement they are two things namely
on the one hand he let himself be
annoyed wittgenstein has of course been annoyed about the poker world dad
has it so easy to
hammer out simple laws or to say clearly
one can talk meaningfully about ethical laws
and on the other hand I think
say  to be able to say that wittgenstein also
fought with himself, yes
, i actually do what you shouldn't
think now after this first
appearance and he also
fought with himself because he had to
apply this
strictness to himself, yes, not about ethics  reden and
wittgenstein was a deeply mystical
and religious person who actually dealt a lot
with these
topics he was driven by these
questions where from where where do we come from we are
so far these things have driven him deeply
and he even writes
in the tractatus that must  you can also
see that the other wittgenstein is
screaming  bt that already in the tractatus
we feel that even if all
sorts of scientific questions are
answered
our life problems are not even touched on it has already occurred to him that if we only remain scientifically clean that we will not
even touch on our life problems yes because science
says  he has a really big
problem she can explain the whole universe
maybe big
bang expansion everyone is but she
always explains how but never why he
said literally not how the world
is is the mystical but that it
is yes that it is  is the real
secret and of course
science can't explain that and of
course it's bad for you because as a
logician he imposed himself
not to talk about it at the same time of
course he was totally busy he read
crisp decree pascal decree also
tolstoy and he
how should i put it  has dealt a lot with
music soda  ss even his
teacher and friend russell, also a
famous english
philosopher, reminded you that he should
n't concern himself too much with music
, he was logica and
wittgenstein answered how can i be a
logician if i'm not human yet,
yes  more of a deeply split
personality also in this regard
it has driven and
today's philosophical research today
speaks of the eloquent silence
of ludwig wittgenstein i think that's
a fantastically good
formulation because he himself says
yes
what you can talk about about it  one has to
be silent but he says it right
away everything we can talk about doesn't really satisfy us
and that's why the
wittgenstein researchers rightly say that this commandment to
remain silent, which he imposes on all of us and on
himself, can at the same time be an implicit
request that we very
well privately ourselves  than people this
w  eg go and also act ethically well
so wittgenstein researchers say there
is definitely an ethics of action and in
later writings he
didn’t formulate this nonsensical side so
massively
and the second thing was he then
noticed something himself, namely his
tractatus wants it  it quickly became the
tractatus quickly became the bible of
positivism yes both in germany
and in england about all the
most positive ones said yes in the future
science will only be what can be positively verified
and
he himself but if you then really
say that really only the truth
this is what we can test experimentally in
reality, so
sentences that can be tested, only
logically meaningful sentences if you apply this
to the tract itself
and you were told that, then
you also have a problem because the
tractatus itself is an
epistemology  where he says what can
we recognize and what not that one can
i  m year did not empirically prove
happened writes and now of
course he was very bright he was
absolutely fit now he
noticed himself and that's why he writes there in the
tractatus in the penultimate sentence writes because
I think it's the penultimate left me
fixed can also be the penultimate
the penultimate thank you there writes yes yes
we have the stone expert here in the
penultimate sentence writes there my sentences
explain that the one who
understands me in the end
recognizes them as nonsensical if he has gone beyond them through
them so the
everyone who him  read and understood well
said must also recognize its status as
nonsensical because you ca
n’t prove them empirically either, but
you can still use it like a
ladder that you
throw away when you’ve reached the new level and
claim validity but still, yeah,
fine  tractatus brings remained the
only work he published during his
lifetime, but in old age
made a second really big discovery
one therefore also speaks of wittgenstein
1 and wittgenstein 2 or of early and
late wittgenstein the second big
discovery was again the
language one could say something new
but then came up with this fantastic theory
of language games which i give you
now I want to bring it closer to you, which
i consider almost even more important,
namely said the language is not
only used to make
clean scientific sentences about the
world as claimed in the tractatus, but he has namely he
has in him it was enough in cambridge
he has  said he just stays at the
university then he first withdrew from
his blog and
at some point in the first world war he was
supposed to have officers too and then
at some point he retired as an
elementary school teacher to the Austrian
province after bach and
where he all the students babbled
heard he noticed the yelling at
the give  commands the
prepare the motivate the all this has
nothing to do with real descriptions of
the world and therefore this quote
will show you the variety of
language games with these examples and
others so the language is
many more diverse than that we just
describe reality and  then there are a
few examples commanding and acting according to
commands describing an
object reporting on a course of events making
up a hypothesis and testing
a story inventing
a play making a joke and asking
thanking cursing great things praying it's all
that's all language so it
's crazy what the  language are
all and this liveliness of the language
that is now being examined
and he comes to the conclusion that the
demand made in the tractatus
that we have to develop an ideal
scientific language
by the way the winter circle and can
then did it can has wasted years with
it or he has  years since  with brought
about to develop an ideal language
in which no errors can occur in the
description of
reality that has failed the attempt
yes and wittgenstein said is here almost
already it can not work because there are
also too many words that already have two
different meanings
for  example, the sentence after its tractatus would make
perfect sense a bank is
a man-made
device to sit down
now is but at the same time you could say
a bank is a credit institution and
both sentences are correct although they are
contradictory so the problem
is there are words that have  so many
different meanings that for that
reason alone we cannot describe things clearly with words
, including the
word five when the daughter comes home and
so my mother said to me i have
martin 5 or when she comes home and
says i will come at 5 this afternoon i
will die  five or she comes bucket
and says my girlfriend  en for
your birthday there are five like this time
the five means something different once
a quality of your grade once a
quantification of the friends once
a time so the five can always
or in my mobile phone has a
display diagonal of 5 then it is a
centimeter indication so the words
depending  how we use them has a
different meaning and a key
sentence is the meaning of a
word its use in the language is
good and the language is just far too
lively to generate exact precise usage
forms
and that is why he says
it is crucial to the meaning
one word thinks about what
does a god decide
language games mean and we all move around
in so
-called language games our whole life and i will
give you the definition of language games
which is the center of his late work
he says firstly language games are the
language forms with which  a child begins
to use words  n so
once you can say it to papa mama then you
start to get into the language
game that the first definition he
speaks of so-called primitive
languages ​​is
good for him but secondly
every communication between two
people he describes as a language game
if they share one  common
rules before following often even
common rules are
then compared to a chess game
chess players can only
play together because they follow common rules
if one of them
moves the rook diagonally and
hits it something is going on
or if the other in the knight then
simply  everyone jumps over it and so
there isn't one they have to follow exactly the same set of
rules and the language is the
same we can only play a
sports game if we have a
common set of rules
following the rules is important chinese meets the
spaniard the speeches three hours more
exciting no one speaks  word chinese
and vice versa  rt then yes in the
end it comes to me everything is Chinese before
the Chinese woman vice versa yes they ca
n't we need that the second
definition of sport game that we
regulate together for you i brought you the
famous construction worker example from
wittgenstein himself
such a  simple language would be that
their function is to inform
a master
mason, i.e. a master mason
their function is to inform
a master mason a with his
assistant
bgh erects a tree
how hands him the building blocks there are
cubes slabs beams should call out one of
the words cubes slab et cetera house
then bring him the stone to the call
five tiles he goes to where the
tiles are stacked up says the
numerals from 1 to 5 picks up
a tile for each word so taylor 5 1 2 3
4 5 and bring it to him
and this one he says  Wittgenstein
also follow the
common rule that knows exactly
the meanings of
each  words and they have a
common rule number system so the
from one to ten you know exactly what
that is and both the same only
works
and the language can even be
expanded say we are coming new
stones then he asks what that is he
said but that  a prism and then
the prism is also with the game well that
's an example of a
simple language game thirdly he
says but language is the
whole of a language i also call it a
language game i will also describe the whole of the
language and the activities  with which
it is interwoven call the language game
so
far it all sounds banal what should be of course
we all live in the
multitude of language games
logically everything makes sense but what does he want to tell us
with that and now it will
soon find a lot more exciting language games  never in a
vacuum city but always
correspond exactly to our way of life that is a
revolutionary sentence that s  speaking the
language is part of an activity or
a way of life
that is so important
because we will see
that in a moment that language is part of a way of life
so language reflects everything is reflected
in the language
game our family upbringing you
know as children you will
not be able to purely born language game
choose then there are language games with people of the
same age with empty mentors and so
on then there are also
language games for society as a whole
at work you have corresponding games
and you as scientists
also have language games we philosophers here have
language games nuclear physicists also have
language games programmers and can
even a human being can  play different
language games in one day he
is a programmer at work
programmed in a team maybe even
a new language in a new
computer language then in the afternoon
at home and in the boxing club he maybe a
trainer trains like that and boxers say knocko to him
now  ut now cover from the bottom
left and so and speaks in the boxer
save bank has that a child in his
arms and makes animal noises yes or so
we are full of how he also
tries to speak to him but he speaks
different languages ​​yes many
different language games and in
everything is condensed in the way we speak so
that’s this sentence speaking
the language is part of an activity
or a way of life that provides information
about our society and about our
personal biography yes that’s
reflected in language play and that’s why he
can say it works  already starting in the
first game the child learns a lot of
things believe notice what the child
learns learns a lot of things believe
that it learns to act according to this belief, for example,
a system of beliefs gradually develops
so they are
not without them  language games that condition
a system of beliefs i used to have as a
student with my girlfriend at the
time  din often
babysat communists who used to
reintroduce the captain the boss of the workers federation
we often looked after their children
and the little one then
i look through the picture book with him
the concrete talk and then all the
picture book something became a child
cloud but  apple and reaches for the policeman
or scolds then i
also read the speech bubble yes and the
policeman gets angry and scolded and
then the little one says he should only be
angry the cop
therefore also said play language games
so up to 20 they only
say minimally like that  reality of life is
definitely good
and the dimension says there is also
what we call adults because what we now think
is more and more blatantly right and
wrong is a reflection
of what we are talking about
a
language game so you say that the
agreement of people decides  don't know
what is right and what is wrong and then
wittgenstein says
yes because maybe a student said that and
then he himself says
what people say is right and wrong and
people agree on the language and of
course there's a crazy
explosive element in it when people
actually
consider what is right and wrong in which
they agree in the language then
has is a language game highly explosive
matter yes and wittgenstein himself was
rather apolitical but he
opened pandora's box and it is interesting
for example even then the question goes
the language game one  new way of life
ahead or does the way of life change first
and then our language game
, e.g. the French enlightenment
the developers offer the euro they
wrote the lexicon they wrote new
language games they introduced new
terms, for example
equality freedom fraternity and
the king he
didn’t like it  by the way the
dikta  fools and kings have always
feared language games they have
always tried to
control the game the censorship i claim is
almost as old as the language itself so
at least until the first state
organization works then we will have the
censorship because such new language games for
example in the language game in the  the people were
then also the sentence who should govern the people
if i the people that was
really stupid for the king because he was king by the
grace of god such
language games it was about the demo he was
constantly in prison after every second
article was the euro  back in prison
and as if the sixteenth and
the revolution had taken place, the
censorship also had no effect and they took
him to the cell in prison
there were a few books
lying around, among other things by Russians, he wanted and that he
said these two men
have destroyed france that would
mean he basically said nothing else
than that these two mä  nner also
voltaire rousseau through their
language games basically started the revolution
so here would be if
one interpreted language game a
new language game a new way of life can
precede it also vice versa be
dictators I can also
think of something that makes the whole
thing vivid hitler went with  wittgenstein went to
school together they were at the same school in linz
hitler was older but wittgenstein
was a grade higher that is
uncomplicated and but there is
also
speculation that they knew
each other but that is
not scientifically verifiable as far as i know
but it doesn't matter
whether they knew each other, hitler also
actually recognized the power of language
and writes in mein kampf
first of all the language play of the germans must be
radically changed and
then,
by the way, he still writes these basic rules of the propaganda of the film
in each  textbook about  repeat good advertising
over and over again keep it short bring in
a few terms penetrating language
game and
among other things the terms completely
public health aryan race
superior and so on and on the
other hand enemies of the people yes people
pests
parasites etc and then completely new
language games were played and he has it in
the propaganda yes  already used in the election
campaign later when
we were in power it changed a bit there it is then
a kingdom a people a leader after the co-
ordination but also david the
conscious attempt to
control language games and
to change language games yes and what the inter plays
a role so it  it certainly also played a
role that
euthanasia programs
could be carried out in germany without much resistance
then he prepared such a language game
and you can see how enormously
explosive it is now
says wittgenstein when language games
change the terms change and with them
also understood the meaning of the
words
a simple example in the middle
ages there was still such a language game ustream
lured so if he came before
and a farmer got married then he could
show up at the wedding say
ustream whether he
could take the bride with him with the language game and could in
latin  means is the right of the
first night to take them to his castle
and spend a night with you then
had to bring them back yes today
versions boss to the employee he
showed the bird yes or even shows it at the
time and that's why
wittgenstein says he loses  so the
term in the case bring news
attracted so it does not have the
unprecedented primary optics of
me so the term loses its
meaning for us that we can
no longer play a certain language with
the play so if the term
has lost its meaning for us  no one can
play a language game with such a term anymore yes he says johanna
so ver  certain language
games lose importance others become important and so
gradually the
use of the vocabulary of our language
changes and very gradually the
changes eg you can i can also use them
that i can show you briefly not
name a  a few terms and you
can easily assign them to the epoch of the
game
barbarians patricia
romans roman antiquity or tunnels
bound farmer
so far exactly why
do we know immediately middle ages or
modern times it might be even easier
burnout blackout if it
becomes completely clear this  language game, for example, if i had
2 amg in the middle ages and said
i just have to do a week
full of wellness, otherwise I’ll get a
burnout, yes, you wouldn’t have
understood that, so
language games lose
importance again, others become important, good
and that’s why he says that’s our language
a beautiful condition enjoy
it is  t enjoy is i think that
one of the most beautiful of wittchen
rise yes our language can be seen
as an old town a
gain of guests and places old and new
houses and houses with additions from
different times around this surrounded
by a lot of new ones i had before
i think it's great or that the
language we speak that these
words are comparable to the houses of
a city there is an old town with
old houses then there are new houses
so just new houses and there are even
houses
to build as solid ones on the sides yes
because the piece was renewed, e.g.
old words that we still have,
I think the wheel breaking is a great word
or weigh which medieval ones
you weighed everything, so from now on we’ll weigh it,
go to the cinema or because we
always think of the real scales, that’s where we
come from  There are only old words in
the spar, but there are also
modern words like
I've already mentioned bodystyling
wellness or  little what do my
boys have are they didn't
relax counted them yes we're chilling now go
crazy or and then there's also
like wittgenstein said in our city
of language old houses with extensions
to buildings like they are the old word
campaign the lance  moved into the field or
campaign in French or campus
also means the field campaign is the
same today we associate it with it so ancient
is 9 then the campaign becomes the
advertising campaign
or the campaign becomes the crossmedia
or multimedia campaign so there
we have the where old with new easy
connected and so the language grows and
then there are completely new quarters around it
and so we have to
imagine it
and the nice thing is again
when the language games change, the terms change
and with the terms the
meanings of the words and now comes next
a second dimension that you
can see how important these language games
are because wittgenstein now also
says that  is not without because if
we agree on something in the language game
then it is also like that and it also
serves to
justify our current way of life you know way of life and
fun play always belong together and when
in modern times then suddenly the
colonial
efforts of many European powers
there  were there one spoke of
colonial lords and one spoke of the wild
of the Indians of the hunter of the wild and
the wild was logical you have to civilize you have to
proselytize they are pagans and savages you have to
proselytize or you put them in a
reservation
around there is in the  language actually
already imperialistic the
justification in it that's why
wittgenstein can say what people accept as
justification shows how
they think and live he could also
say shows how they think speak and
live because language always contains
legitimation good and
that's why  he can say new language games
as we can say arise on  their
behavior and will be forgotten there is of
course an enormous explosive charge in it
wittgenstein himself was surprisingly
apolitical who never spoke politically
back to the national team to other
things he was very reticent
after him however it broke
up interestingly herbert
marcuse then said that would be
straight  to wittgenstein's self-
flagellation that the philosopher must not
criticize language games because who
will den stone said
philosophy must not touch the actual
use of language in any way
it can only describe it in the end
and that is why it is imperative
describe language games so wittgenstein has pointed them out
already demanded
that we practice language criticism that was also
his demand but by
language criticism he didn't
mean that we should criticize the content
and say that is the fascist
language or ideology practice criticism with
criticism Wittgenstein meant that we
simply  ch take a critical look at how
exactly the word is used in which language
game to get to the point of the use of the
original words
he says you should do
the work of taking all the
philosophical words and
looking at how they are used in everyday
language  and then to see what
the philosopher makes of it then
one would recognize the nonsense yes well he wants to
use language criticism basically he only wants to
describe there were also strict again
but after him it
started with critical theory
and all of them
then of course our language games
have criticized
well
now what is still interesting what we
can take away from wittgenstein at the end he says we ca
n't get out of the language games but
we can change them and he himself
was a very restless spirit he was
always looking for a completely new atmosphere
and he also says bring
people into the wrong atmosphere
u  nd nothing will work as it
should urgently get back into the right
element and everything will unfold
and appear healthy also a very
strong quote yes and by that he also means
the language games you can be totally
unhappy and if you have other
language games come up with other people
with others  people can say yes he is
better again he himself was a
driven person he has changed completely again and again
he was not only
now in the military as a
volunteer he was a nurse he
was has two nationalities he
was or then changed he was also
that once  i was very withdrawn there was a
gardener’s assistant in a monastery
then was the elementary school teacher in the
rearmost province in austria
and then he was even an architect
once when he actually has an engineer
he studied philosophy they came
involuntarily because the questions tormented them so much
and as an architect  he
didn't want to deprive them of that from
his sch  wester built a house and you
know it sounds strictly logical and
his sister after the house was
finished and she has already secured it in europe
she said the house turned to stone
again logic yes
and no sorry house
turned logic she said yes i will show
you briefly  you see, and wittgenstein did
n't leave anything to chance he had the
radiators in a very modern design, the
door handles, everything and also
insisted that the chandeliers shouldn't be
so opulent but it's a very
ascetic style and because
i want to show you that you
the people of wittgenstein also still have a
little bit in their heads yes he was also
a self-critical spirit and then he
writes it himself my house for gretel
is the product of decidedly fine
deference to good manners but the wild
life that wants to let off steam is chosen
one could also say he misses it  health
that's wittgenstein so in conclusion i
'll summarize when i say wittgens  wanting to express tein's
philosophy in one sentence i
would say wittgenstein set out
with his tractatus to rid the world
of nonsensical philosophical questions
once and for all, but he
was far too much of a philosopher
himself not to have asked the big questions himself
, all three big ones at that
philosophical questions first the
geological question or
epistemological question what can
i know second the ontological
question what is that being yes and that 1
third the ethical question what is the
good and its answer was always the
same namely the language because the
language determines the horizon  what
can't know and shows us what we
can think of at all we can only think of the world in
terms of language and logically language is determined
expression of our whole way of life everything
is language and the ethical question is
what people in the respective
epoch focus on in their language game and in  the
respective company and i  in your
four groups, what is
generally
considered ethically binding is also good, that's why the
stone was the very great philosopher of
language and so he calls and he calls
and be the last to the
language game as the premiere thank you very much
[  Applause]